Hey everyone.  What do hotels, cruise lines, airlines and parking lots all have in common?
They're not just selling their products, they're also selling space.
And that space runs out.
This is the world of capacity constrained pricing.
What we're going to look at in this video are two key ideas.
One, how to price when you have limited capacity and two, how demand forecasts shape those pricing decisions.  Let's dive into it.
Imagine you have a hotel.
You're managing this hotel.
You've got 300 rooms and tonight they're all empty.
Now here's the catch.
Whether you sell 0 rooms or 300, your fixed cost, such as your staff, salaries, electricity, insurance are already paid and you can't get that money back.
These are called sunk costs.
So what should you focus on instead?
In the short run, pricing is all about this marginal revenue and marginal cost.
What do I earn from selling one more unit?
Marginal revenue versus what does it cost to serve one more customer?
That's our marginal cost.
If our marginal revenue is greater than our marginal cost, then we want to sell.
But if our marginal revenue is less than our marginal cost, then we don't want to sell.
We actually want to back away from that.
So let's say the cost to clean a room and service it is $40.
That's the marginal cost.
If we can sell this room at a hundred dollars, then that's our marginal revenue and we pocket $60.
So that's pretty easy.  We sell that room at a hundred dollars and we profit 60.
But what if demand is weak and instead each room only costs $50?
We had to lower the price in order to bring people in.
Well, we still want to make this sale because $50, our marginal revenue is greater than our marginal cost of 40.
So in this case you profit $10.
So hey, $10 beats zero, you make that sale.
So that's the logic of pricing the field to capacity.
As long as the room covers its marginal cost, then it should be filled.
Airlines live and breathe by this principle.
They also want to price to fill to capacity.
Plane has a fixed number of seats.
Fuel, crew and takeoff costs are mostly fixed.
So that last minute deal that you snagged, well, that's that airline pricing to fill available capacity.
It's a strategic move by that airline.
They want to sell those seats because the marginal revenue for them is greater than the marginal cost.
Let's look at this in graphical terms.
Here we have our price and quantity of rooms or could be seats or parking spots or anything.
Our capacity is a constraint.
Anytime where our marginal revenue is greater than our marginal cost.
We want to lower that price until we get that sweet spot where marginal cost and marginal revenue are equal to each other.
So if we have 300 rooms and we price it at $100 and our marginal revenue goes our marginal cost, then we can't do any better.
At that point, we've maximized our profit.
Any point beyond that, we are minimizing our profit.
We actually are going to experience loss because our marginal cost is greater than our marginal revenue.
Any point before that, $100.
So at 200 rooms, what we're going to find is that we could actually make more money because our marginal revenue is greater than our marginal cost.
So we want to get to the point where our marginal revenue and marginal cost are equal to each other.
Now, what happens if we have some uncertainty that comes into play here?
We need to forecast our demand and our pricing models.
This is where we are.
We're going to do a little bit of simulations.
So the hotel, the airline, and the stadium, they're all trying to figure out how many, how many rooms do I sell, how many, how, you know, how many seats can I sell, how many, what price do I use in order to get to the point where our marginal revenue because our marginal cost.
But they deal with uncertainty.
All right, you've got 100 rooms, you've got 300 seats, you've got thousands of seats in your stadium.
You need to forecast out what prices are going to help you feel to capacity.
So here, how many rooms will be booked this weekend?
These are questions that our managers are going to be looking at.
Will there be a surge in travelers tomorrow?
Will demand drop if it rains on a game day?
All these things need to be taken into consideration when you're trying to forecast your particular demand.
These forecasts, we know, are never perfect.
So what we want to do is have a confidence interval that bounds around our demand curve.
So it might be low on some days, it might be higher on others.
And we're going to use things like expected analysis to help us figure out what price we we want to get to in order to get to the point where marginal revenue is equal to our marginal cost.
Now, we know sometimes we may overprice, sometimes we may underprice.
Which mistake is more costly to us?
If we overprice, we're going to lose revenue and have unused capacity.
If we underprice, we're going to sell out.
But that also means we're going to leave some money on the table.
All right, so one, we have more capacity than what we Wanted.
And two, we don't have enough capacity.
And we, and we love and we lost some money on that.
So this is probabilistic pricing strategy.
It's a thing that we have to look at in our management strategies here.
Now, let's compare two extremes.
We have this luxury hotel and we have this parking lot.
The luxury hotel might price high just to protect its brand.
All right, so this means that it's not going to fill every room.
That parking lot, on the other hand, it's downtown.
It might have a little bit of maintenance that it requires, but it's got underpriced to guarantee all those spots are sold.
So it's going to try to fill its capacity.  Why?
Because once the space sits empty, it's lost forever.
All right, so let's say our forecast says the man will likely be here.
We're gonna do an example here.
Let's say that our forecast is going to say, hey, we can have, we got a number of rooms here, all right, we can price these at 200 per room, but we get fewer guests.
Or we could price it $150 and we'll fill more rooms, but we're earn less per stay.
So what do we do in this case?  What do we sign?
We're going to use expected value analysis to help us calculate the optimal pricing policy.
So at $200, this is what we are figuring.
40% chance of only booking 40 rooms, 60% chance of booking 20 rooms.
All right, so let's do the math.
We're going to price the 40% at $200 and sell the 40 rooms and then the 60% chance at $200 and 20 rooms.
When we do the math, we get $5,600 in total revenue from this expected value analysis.
Now let's do the $150, 70% chance of booking 60 rooms and only a 30% chance of booking 30 rooms.
So let's put our numbers in here.
70% times 150 times the 60 plus 30% times 150 times the 30 rooms that we sell.
And we get $7,650 and in revenue.
So this is actually the better deal for us.
And we want to price at $150 because the expected value analysis tells us that we're going to generate more revenue from pricing at a lower price than at that higher price.
All right, so this is what we see.
Now, one thing to keep in mind, a lot of times, this just isn't a one and done deal.
So we might price it at 150 today.
But firms are going to want price in real time.
So they're going to see things unfolding, maybe demand picks up, maybe demand slows down, and they're going to want to adjust their prices in real time based off of what happens whenever they see demand changing.
All right, so let's move on here.
Now let's bring in time as a dimension in our pricing.
Now, firms are going to be looking at short run and long run decisions in the short run.
In the short run, they're going to be looking at pricing to the point where marginal revenue equals marginal cost.
This is what we've already covered up to this point.
But in the long run, you can invest and expand your parking lot, your stadium, whatever it happens to be.
So now this firm has to take into account, or these firms have to take into account, how much do we bring in in the long run versus what it's going to cost us to expand on our operation?
So how do we know if it's worth it?
Well, we want to compare our long run marginal revenue to our long run marginal cost.
That means if the expected extra revenue from adding additional capacity is greater than the cost of actually doing it, then you go ahead and do that.
So you only expand if your long run marginal revenue is greater than or equal to your long run marginal cost.
So let's work with an example here.
You can already see I've got the solution already marked down.
We're going to be looking at stadium expansion and our current capacity is 20,000.
We sell out every weekend for 30 events per year.
The average ticket price is $75.
Now, the proposal is to add in 1,000 extra seats.
And what we're going to see here is our forecast says we could sell those extra seats at 80% of the time and at that current average ticket price of $75.
So here we're going to have 1,000 times 30 events, times the 80% fuel rate to give us 24,000 extra tickets sold per year.
Now, what does that give us in terms of our long run marginal revenue?
Multiply the 24,000 extra seats per year or tickets per year by the $75 and we get $1.8 million generated per year.
Okay, what is our long run marginal cost?
Well, that is the actual building, that capacity and maintenance and service and all that other stuff that goes along with serving that extra capacity.
So here, construction costs to build those thousand seats or $3 million, and we're going to put that at $300,000 for 10 years.
Then the additional staff we're just going to say it's $500 per event times the 30 events of $15,000 a year to to staff those extra 1,000 seats and then the additional maintenance, whatever that happens to be on those seats, 60,000 a year.
Now what we want to do is add in all these additional costs.
These are our extra marginal costs that go into these 1,000 seats and we get our long run marginal cost of doing this 1,000 seats is $375,000 per year.
So in this case we do see our long run marginal revenue is greater than our long run marginal cost.
So what we see, let's just wrap all this up.  What we see here.
In the short run, you price to feel to capacity so you don't lose any extra money.
You don't get to the point where your margin revenue is greater, greater than or equal to your marginal cost.
We use forecasts to guide how aggressive or conservative our pricing should be in the long run.
We still use marginal analysis, decide whether we want to grow or stay with what we have.
And then pricing here we know isn't guesswork, it's going to be more strategy.
We want to look at how we, we can bring in the expected value analysis to help us figure out, you know, where should we be pricing our seats, our parking lots, whatever it happens to be, where should we pricing those?  And that's it.
Hope you've enjoyed it.